the divine poet dante famously
told us that there is no greater sorrow
than to recall
good times during times of misery and
right now
if if we're talking about politics
things are pretty miserable even down to
forget about who's president forget
about the policies
even down to the erasure of president
trump's
twitter account and nevertheless i want
to recall the good times
i want to look back on those wonderful
four years forget about the policy
forget about the diplomacy i want to
look back on four years
of president trump's tweets let's get
[Music]
started
we're not going to have time to get
through all of these tweets they're
they're all
there are so many good ones this is just
one small fraction of all the great
tweets to begin though
classic happy cinco de mayo the best
taco bowls are made in trump tower grill
i love hispanics
i love it at the time you had all these
really fancy republicans and they said
oh my gosh this is so offensive
it's not offensive at all it actually it
was both very funny
and really leveled with people and with
hispanic voters right instead of trying
to dance around the issue he said hey
hispanic voters i want you to vote for
me i like your food
and i like that you're in america and i
like that we're going to americanize
your
food and you should come eat taco bowls
at trump tower
and it's it's so promoting of his own
brand i think it's just
great so funny classic trump and he made
inroads with hispanic voters even though
people said he was going to destroy the
gop with hispanic voters next one
trump writing about uh representative
rashida talib talib wrote a letter
to israeli officials desperately wanting
to visit her grandmother
permission was quickly granted whereupon
talib obnoxiously turned the approval
down
a complete setup the only real winner
here is talib's grandmother
she doesn't have to see her now
this is a minor political scandal but at
the time it was a big deal but they said
rashida talib because she hates israel
isn't going to be allowed to go in to
visit her mother
in the disputed territories in israel or
her grandmother rather
and uh so then you know the u.s
government and israel they say okay fine
to leave you can come she goes oh i
don't want to do that i just want a
showboat
this is all good now she doesn't have to
see her now
next one while not at all presidential i
must point out that the
sloppy michael moore show on broadway
was a total bomb
and was forced to close sad
yeah you have to include this there is
so many tweets that ended with sad
trump's tweeting of sad actually made
that a punch line like you would i would
hear this i would do it myself
whenever you'd have some sort of bad
news you could say such and such you
know sorry johnny we can't go to dinner
tonight
sad it's just
there's something they always said this
wasn't presidential because the
president of the united states should
not
reach down you know and answer his
critics in this way but trump doesn't
care trump's an absolute fighter and he
calls him
sloppy michael moore and always goes
after the ratings and this was this was
actually a secret with trump the reason
they couldn't kick him off social media
is because he was just so popular and
the reason that the news
the news cameras couldn't turn off him
why cnn couldn't stop covering him he
was great for ratings and all those
other guys were very bad for ratings
that is a true
showman and politician not much of a
difference next one in the beautiful
midwest
wind chill temperatures are reaching
minus 60 degrees the coldest ever
recorded and coming day is expected to
get even colder people can't last
outside even for minutes
what the hell is going on with global
warming please come back
fast we need you
so he's i love it because he's making a
joke out of it and i think politics goes
down a little easier
when you make it funny and trump is
extremely funny funniest president we've
ever had i also liked it because
all this fancy people said oh please
pish-posh
climate and weather are different
weather has nothing to do with climate
because trump is saying look why is it
so cold that i thought it was global
warming but you notice all those fancy
people who have the sophisticated
distinction
anytime there is any kind of weather
event
warm weather or hurricane or something
any weather event that they think
can be exploited to justify their
climate theory
then they always cite it then weather
and climate are the same thing but then
when you
cite whether in the opposite direction
none weather and climate are completely
different very
very funny stuff next one why would kim
jong-un insult me by calling me old when
i would never
call him short and fat oh well i try so
i can't even get through this one this
was this was one of my favorites of time
oh well i try so hard to be his friend
and maybe someday that will happen
see the only way to deal with a lunatic
dictator of a nuclear power overseas is
to make yourself
seem just as crazy right to make
yourself so unpredictable this actually
was the trump foreign policy
was be unpredictable and by the way
trump had greater foreign policy
achievements than any president in our
lifetime
perhaps with the exception of george h.w
bush he might certainly since george h.w
bush no one had better
foreign policy achievements than trump
and just who who does that
i would never call him short and fat i
try so hard to be his friend
another kim jong-un one north korean
later kim jong-un just stated that the
nuclear button is on his desk at all
times will someone from his depleted and
food-starved regime please inform him
that i too have a nuclear button
but it is a much bigger and more
powerful one than his and my button
works
people were furious the fancy people in
america they were so
upset foreign policy stuff you can't say
that you're
threatening the entire purpose of having
a nuclear arsenal
is that the credible threat of violence
will stop
the other guy from doing something rash
the entire purpose of having a nuclear
arsenal
is this tweet but for so long you had
these weak
ignorant politicians who would come out
and say no we would never use nuclear
weapons
well if you would never use them what's
the point of having them they're only a
provocation if you would never
use them trump obviously understood
strength
he would have peace through strength and
he also understood that he would have
political rule through
humor next one this one was so brilliant
because it was multimedia
look at this photograph look at this
photograph
is playing into this nickelback
playing into hunter biden playing
there's so many memes
in this meme i i assume dan scavino or
one of these other
sort of social media advisors had
something to do with this one and then
trump played into it
really really smart stuff and this
actually i know we're all laughing about
it now
this will be studied in political
science courses in universities
that kind of media use in the same way
that fdr
is studied for using the radio trump
will be studied for that kind of
multimedia
on on the social networks next one this
one's a little self-serving for us at
the daily wire american hero and
it was uh trump putting the medal of
pawner
on the dog that killed al baghdadi
really terrific this became a big
scandal they called us a fake news site
is they just the left-wingers thought we
were trying to seriously convince people
that president trump gave them the medal
of partner
something that totally exists to to a
dog this is
armageddon really funny glad the
president enjoyed it we certainly did
too
next one beautiful weather all over our
great country a perfect day for all
women to march get out there now to
celebrate the historic milestones in
unprecedented economic success
and wealth creation that has taken place
over the last 12 months lowest female
unemployment in 18 years
now the thing i don't like about this
tweet is i don't care about female
unemployment i think women should be
perfectly entitled to stay home and
raise a family
i don't think it's a mark of a great
society that we send all of our women
out
to work in the factories and be middle
managers at the widget company
however trump's just trolling them right
there's the women's march which is just
explicitly anti-trump
he's saying yes get out there and
celebrate all my great achievements very
funny stuff
next one i was actually sticking up for
sleepy joe biden while on foreign soil
kim jong-un called him a low iq idiot
and many other things whereas i related
the quote of chairman kim
as a much softer low iq individual
who could possibly be upset with that
i don't know he did he actually did he
did help him out it was very
very uh kind of him and frankly either
of those quotes i think are giving mr
biden
probably a little too much credit i just
love when trump does it sort of with the
smirk like
what what me who me like alfred newman
next one of course this is a classic
this this may actually be the best one
despite the constant negative press
coffee i thought this actually summed up
sort of the trump approach to politics
which is presumably he just
had a typo whatever and he sent it by
accident and then he just left it up he
left it up for like 12 hours and then
the next day he joked about he says what
does koffe mean
i don't know who can tell us that that
is actually right
if he were worried about the negative
press he just deleted it right away and
explained it but he doesn't care about
the negative press despite
the constant negative press coffee good
advice to all of us and then my
single absolute favorite president trump
tweet this was from april 17 2017
a great book for your reading enjoyment
reasons to vote for democrats by michael
j knowles
the way that this tweet came about i had
just published this blank book
uh it had jumped up amazon i go on fox
and friends in the morning it's 4 00 a.m
or so in
la so in the east coast you know seven
o'clock or something
and i go on do the thing and we'd
already done the joke about the blank
book so they asked me about president
trump i
complimented something he had done and
then i saw there was a
sort of misquote of what i had said but
it came out from the president's twitter
account
and then right afterward an endorsement
of the book and i thought oh my goodness
gracious
this president is the most transparent
and accessible president we have ever
seen
he is actually up there actually manning
the station
watching fox news in the morning telling
jokes
having a good time with it that is the
sort of language of a guy who was
thriving in the job who really enjoyed
the job some presidents they seem to
hate it and they get
angry and crestfallen and not trump he
seemed to become more and more
alive and we're gonna miss it i enjoyed
every minute of those tweets
goodbye president trump twitter account
you are gone
but you will not be forgotten
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you